We are about to begin a journey beyond ordinary
human understanding
Lost somewhere between immensity and eternity
Join me, as we explore: Our Amazing
Debt
We are all made of star stuff -- and in America, we're all born more than 61
thousand dollars in debt
The collective debt we owe as a country now stands at 20 trillion dollars
A level of debt unfathomable to our contemptible
caveman ancestors
How can we comprehend the sheer magnitude of our national debt?
With our starship of imagination
This is the USS Dumbitdownforme
and it cost 12 billion dollars to construct
all financed through debt
We didn’t have the money to build it and
we didn’t want to raise taxes to pay for it
but we really wanted it
So, like a fiscal wormhole, we’ve used debt
to puncture the reality of financial constraints
connecting what we want now to promises of paying even more money later
Let’s take a look inside and see what
20 Trillion dollars really means
20 trillion dollars isn’t just a lot of
money, it’s all of the money, and then some
If we could round up all the US currency in
existence - every dollar bill, every quarter, every penny
we'd still need another 18 Trillion dollars
All the gold that’s ever
been mined couldn’t even cover half of our debt
Yet our story doesn't end here
Like our ever-expanding universe
our debt is constantly growing larger
This year we'll pay more than 250 billion dollars on interest payments
not the debt, just the fee for borrowing money
Much as cosmic expansion will inevitably lead to the heat death of our own universe
the debt, too, is unsustainable
As nature seeks balance so too will our creditors
Will the government gut spending? Defund entitlements? Devalue our currency?
One day, perhaps in our lifetime
we will discover the answers and reach the limit of our amazing debt
But for now we can only behold the awesome force that binds all Americans
bewitching us with the fascinating possibility that maybe
just maybe
we're all f*cked